this week the state of michigan
announced a 600
million dollar settlement for the
victims of the flint water crisis
for a year and a half residents
unknowingly drank dangerous leg
contaminated
tap water after the city failed to treat
the water as part of a cost-saving
measure
the contamination also led to a deadly
outbreak of legionnaires disease
today most residents still don't trust
the water which has been deemed safe
some say the settlement is progress but
others want criminal charges
adriana diaz has more
to say 600 million is worth it for us in
our lives
not nearly enough for the damages that
have been done
the settlement doesn't settle much for
many flint residents
but for ariana hawk it's validation it's
been six years that we've been crying
and asking
you know not one but two governors to
actually you know
make us whole again you know we've
begged for people to hear our stories
you know it definitely was like okay
thank you
finally somebody's hearing us finally
somebody believed that what's happened
in flint was wrong
anyone exposed to city water for at
least three weeks from mid-2014 on
can apply for part of the 600 million
dollar payout
roughly 80 percent will go to flint's
children most of the rest to adults and
property owners
for context if you divide the children's
allotment by the roughly 30 thousand
miners affected
that's potentially 16 thousand dollars
per child
it's been more than five years since
officials botched a cost saving measure
to switch the water source to the flint
river
the water was improperly treated causing
lead to leach from pipes
the percentage of kids with elevated
lead levels doubled
putting them at risk for developmental
issues long term
that was top of mind when we first met
hawke in january 2016
when she was getting lead test results
for her son sincere
then nearly three years old and covered
in rashes
sincere was one of the faces of the
crisis as soon as he get in the tub you
can like see it he's digging so bad that
the skin is just like coming off of him
i don't want no kids to have to go
through that
this is sincere today oh my god hi
sincere
hi hi you don't remember me we met a
long time ago
how are you good he's seven and still
has some skin
issues but his mom worries most about
what she can't see
you know just the fact that i'm a mother
who has to
look at her kids and wait to find out
what's going to happen to you you know
our lives have not changed much at all
it still looks like 2015 in flint lines
for bottled water continue to stretch
for blocks
and most people still use it for cooking
and brushing their teeth
i'll never drink flint water again never
never never despite new water mains and
state assurances the water's safe
flint's water is still clouded by a
crisis of trust
it's people still haunted by an
invisible poison and no amount of money
can settle the fear
they still face for cbs this morning
saturday
i'm adriana diaz